that's a great question it's because
when i first started publishing I was
about 23 and I felt like Andy wasn't
going to be taken very seriously so I
called myself Andrew Sean it was the
name my mom would yell out when I was in
trouble so so it felt like I could sort
of take on a persona of maybe an older
sounding person great relief I really
think that's it because you have no idea
what's going to happen and then you're
hugely relieved and sometimes baffled
that they take you that seriously um and
it's a little confusing because you're
all but so full of doubt that they don't
seem to notice at all I grew up in the
suburbs which I don't think shaped me
very much I think what shape me was I
had two parents who were scientists and
especially and they were great readers
they had both grown up in sort of rural
parts of the south and were oddballs
where they grew up they were in budding
intellectuals my mom was a chemist and
used to poison frogs and her backyard
neck anything and so they were we had
tons of books in our house that was
their great solace in their lives they
were the only weirdos and so books were
always this exalted thing so it was they
were very supportive when I wanted to be
a writer they had no sense how anyone
could make money doing that but they
weren't going to stop me because that's
what they admired most think that's
where I got that
you